today we're talking about domains
databricks
vmware engine and budgets i'm jenny and
welcome to this week in cloud where we
serve you
the lowest latency news we're
introducing cloud domains in preview
which simplifies domain registration and
management within google cloud
cloud domains improves the custom domain
experience for developers
increases security and supports stronger
integrations around dns
and ssl it offers easy domain renewal
through cloud billing
and permissions via im check out the
release for more information
by deploying on google cloud databricks
users can build data lakes fast and
integrate data science and ml workloads
on their path towards
production databricks capabilities in
data engineering and analytics are
complemented by google cloud's global
secure network
and all together customers get an
enterprise-ready cloud service with a
databricks experience
that's reliable scalable secure and
governed
read more about this integration on the
blog
google cloud vmware engine simplifies
the challenges of moving
and modernizing critical workloads to
the cloud to make networking
simpler and enhance security management
we've recently released
improved networking support scalability
and support for the vmware platform
and improved reach among other things
check out the blog for the full list
budgets and alerts are probably the
first step to staying on top of your
google cloud costs
if you care about money you should
definitely set up a budget
check out the blog post by mark
michondani to learn more
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see it in the cloud
you